macho man rooster brothers how do you
guys not have any Nova Corp member in a
fight against Thanos love the movie but
just boggles my mind didn't even have to
be Richard Ryder I look closely at that
scene again dear and you will see there
are thousands of people yeah you will
see Richard Ryder in the background of a
shot Easter Egg everyone thank you so
much these were great questions yes yeah
sending in these questions we really
appreciate it and hopefully you got
satisfactory answers yeah and I
hopefully you have answers of your own
hey everybody is Charlie what's going on
why are the Russos talking about Nova
being in The Avengers Assemble scene
from Avengers endgame I almost got more
requests to make a video about this and
I did for the very first trailer for
Avengers endgame it's not what everyone
thinks it is so I'll explain because the
Russos are all over the map when it
comes to talking about stuff like this
because this Nova stuff is so funny also
do a special giveaway for the Avengers
end game special edition boxset blu-rays
all you have to do to enter that is just
be a subscriber and leave your best Nova
theory on the video because Kevin Feige
did say that they are working on a nova
project he just didn't say when it was
coming or whether it would be a movie or
a TV show or whether he would appear in
someone else's movie but what's going on
why is everybody freaking out about Nova
in Avengers end game so I put that clip
at the beginning of this that's part of
a larger Q&A that they did for Wired
where they're answering fans questions
from Twitter and other places all the
Marvel directors get thousands of
questions like this on social media
every day after the movies come out even
after they've long since left Marvel to
go work on other films the Russos aren't
working at Marvel anymore technically
the movie still in theaters they just
started the home video release so of
course they're still making noise about
Avengers endgame they still want people
talking about it but a lot of times
Marvel directors will give people joke
answers just to get them to shut up or
to try to make a joke or be funny Joe
Russo himself though is so deadpan that
sometimes it's hard to tell whether or
not he's joking so you will be forgiven
if you take everything he says at face
value James Gunn has been known to tease
people about unfound Easter eggs during
the original guardians of the galaxy
film and guardians of the galaxy vol 2
but the Russos are taking at next-level
trolling the difference with the James
Gunn
is that he has not done something like
this like he will genuinely tell you
that there is an Easter egg that someone
has not found and he's not lying just to
get people to rewatch guardians of the
galaxy a billion more times for no
reason there were special codes hidden
in the coordinates to know where that
decoded that Peter Quill's father would
be ego the Living Planet there was a
similar code hid in the coordinates to
Ronan ship the dark aster that talked
about Peter Quill's mother's cancer in
the secret behind that but after
avengers endgame came out this past year
everyone was asking the Russos about
comments they had made previously in all
the misleading trailers lying to them
and they pretty much tell you you can't
trust anything that they say can we
trust you anymore like with the trailers
can we the rest is a trust is a relative
really I mean can we can we trust
society its filmmaker if what you're to
be respective or if what you're talking
about is can you trust us mm-hmm to
deliver you an experience in the movie
theater that's going to be fresh and
surprising and one that you can predict
if we give information out can we trust
the Internet to run it yes I trust that
we'll have padmi wants you to look down
the barrel of the camera and go because
it is and we do so if you haven't been
following everything the Marvel people
have ever said about all their movies
for the last ten years
you are totally forgiven for assuming
that everything they say is true it is
not point in fact the Russos said that
the title of Avengers endgame was never
spoken during Avengers infinity war and
we all saw Doctor Strange say we're in
the endgame now so they said that they
did that to protect quote-unquote the
film and also they hadn't decided on the
title so believe them don't believe them
whatever but if you want to be a giant
conspiracy theorist we'll do the
ultimate zoom in enhance so it's
supposed to be this Avengers Assemble
scene when they're all pulling people
out of the portals so you start with the
Black Panther characters then Falcon
Winter Soldier accrued everyone who was
snapped at the Battle of Wakanda
out then Scarlet Witch Valkyrie the
Asgardians court and meek
coming from new Asgard next to them are
the magic users from Kimura Taj and the
other sanctums then the wasp and Pepper
Potts arrived by themselves this is the
scene with Howard the Duck in it and if
you look at this wider shot with the
smaller portals up in the air those are
just more portals from the wakandan
battleships flying through the air so
that they don't have to land them on the
ground and tow them through the lower
portals all of these smaller portals
here up in the air on top of the larger
ones are mostly just extra portals for
the same locations as the larger ones
directly below them zoom and enhance on
the front battle line here you see Wang
the other sorcerers behind him wasp
groot the Ravagers behind them Doctor
Strange in the back spider-man the
Guardians coming from Titan Falcon war
machine Hulk Captain America Thor all
the wakandans behind them black panther
Ironman Scarlet Witch Winter Soldier
even watching the running scene in slow
motion when they take off and they pan
up to the sky across the battlefield
it's just Valkyrie Ironman Pepper Potts
the wakandan airships a few of the
Ravagers ships Falcon Doctor Strange
Scarlet Witch star-lord
all the characters that can fly no Nova
in sight you could comb through every
frame of every battle like this and you
probably wouldn't find him sometimes
visual effects artist will hide stuff in
the background of shots and not tell the
directors about it but in cases like
that it's usually really small stuff
that has nothing to do with the actual
plot there are a lot of Easter eggs for
future Marvel phase 4 and Marvel phase 5
movies I've already done a bunch of
Easter Egg videos for that stuff but the
Russos aren't involved with any of the
future Marvel movies right now a lot of
you may have heard about the alternate
version of Avengers infinity war that
involved the Nova Corps there was a
version of Infinity Ward that had an
extended scene at the beginning of the
movie where Thanos goes to zantar to
take the Power Stone and uses it to
destroy the planet in the entire Nova
Corps including Nova prime but when they
were talking about that version of the
movie they never talked about Richard
Ryder Nova appearing during that there
are a lot of people since then that have
Theory crafted that thes and re and
world mind will mint a new Nova as
revenge for what happened to them that
extinction level event either the Sam
Alexander version or go classic with
Richard Ryder or they'll just do Nova as
a care
during the past in the Captain Marvel
sequels like say there was an OVA at one
point but he lived in the past and he's
dead in present day like I said Kevin
Feige has only mentioned they're
developing an ova project without saying
when it would happen or what it would
look like either Disney Plus series or a
full-blown movie but Marvel phase 5 is
the earliest they could do something
like that just based on what they've
already announced he talked about the
Marvel cosmic universe becoming a much
bigger thing the Marvel space based
movies in addition to the larger Marvel
Cinematic Universe so when you talk
about the Marvel Cinematic Universe
you're talking about everything that's
canon to what's happening during the
movies and now the Avengers endgames
spin-off TV series that are happening on
Disney Plus those will be canon and will
crossover with the movies but separately
from that you have the Marvel cosmic
universe which is just the space based
movies which they said is going to
become a much bigger thing in the next
10 years meaning you'll see a lot more
space-based characters Nova just happens
to be one of the biggest ones they
haven't done yet so of course they're
gonna do them at some point the thing
that changes the timeline all that now
is the addition of all the Fantastic
Four and x-men characters that they have
now they can do Galactus they can do
Silver Surfer they're a bunch of other
space based characters they didn't have
access to before
all of that is spoilers but I'm
extremely excited about those characters
and about and about bringing Marvel's
first family up sort of to the platform
and the level that they deserve are you
anywhere near casting no story no no no
see all the stuff we did today I just
have time to talk about it so don't be
surprised if you hear about a Silver
Surfer movie happening before you hear
about a Nova movie happening hopefully
that explains what all the Nova
craziness was about this morning just
the Russos probably having fun at our
expense so just remember to take
everything they say with a grain of salt
the Marvel d23 panel is happening this
weekend I'll do videos for all the
trailers they drop all the big stuff
that they announced be sure to let me
know in the comments which videos you
want me to make next congratulations
Troy Bryant and eek Carlos you're the
giveaway winners from my last Marvel
videos please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
everybody click here for my Young
Avengers Easter Egg video and click here
for my breakdown of the doctors
multiverse of madness Comic Con teaser
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]